pour apprendre à domestiquer les robots
le cfj de montigny le bretonneux convie
les écoles primaires et les collèges du
bassin de rambouillet a participé au
grand bosquet le principe un étudiant
coach une classe du cm1 à la quatrième à
programmer un robot sur un parcours avec
un objectif final la compétition dans
six mois
ces deux d'amener les études un
communiqué une passion pas seulement à
travailler à de la programmation du
codage de l'organisation et
l'utilisation de robots mais aussi à
considérer l'environnement de ces robots
et l'environnement c'est l'humain donc
pour eux c'est une expérience humaine
avant que d'être une expérience
technique dira-t-on mardi soir les
écoles découvrez le cahier des charges
précis de cette deuxième édition
le robot devra franchir deux portes
contourner un élément est passée sous un
autre le tout dans un décor sur le thème
de la découverte de l'espace pour les
aider des étudiants aux managers des
systèmes informatique et robotique
je suis impatient de leur montrer la
passion que j'ai pour ça et
éventuellement peut-être les inspirer
pour continuer dans ce domaine là plus
tard
l'année dernière le challenge sous le
thème du cirque a connu un succès auprès
des établissements 11 classes
participent cette année avec un grand
enthousiasme des élèves
je trouve ça très intéressant et puis ça
mélange en pet leur discipline
donc ce qui leur permet en fait de faire
des ponts et des liens entre chaque
ça leur donne ça va un peu de concret
dans tout ce qu'on peut leur faire faire
au collège la plupart du temps quoi
reste désormais à apprivoiser ces
petites bêtes pour tenter de remporter
le challenge rambo 2 game à rambouillet
le 15 mai prochain